es bastante desierto las que se pueden
observar a estas horas en el centro de
santiago cuando entra en vigor una de
las cuarentenas más estrictas que ha
vivido chiles que al momento y que
mantendrá bajo un encierro total a 16 de
los 19 millones de chilenos el gobierno
ha suspendido durante este fin de semana
incluso los permisos para salir a
comprar en un intento por frenar la
movilidad y reducir así la transmisión
del virus que en estos días ha marcado
récords en chile- en cuanto al número de
contagios reportados a diario por encima
de los 7.500 casos como ocurría este
sábado esto preocupa porque cuando estas
cifras se traduzcan en ingresos a las
unidades de cuidados intensivos la red
hospitalaria se encuentra ya saturada en
un 96% con unos equipos de salud muy
mermados por los esfuerzos realizados
durante todo un año en la primera línea
contra la pandemia se vienen momentos
muy difíciles anunció este sábado en un
mensaje televisado el presidente del
gobierno sebastián piñera quien realizó
un llamado a reforzar las medidas de
autocuidado y recordó que en la
vacunación en la que chile sigue siendo
un ejemplo mundial tardará en hacer
sentir sus efectos en las cifras de
contagios reportadas a diario metros
cada vez más los expertos y también los
políticos que apuestan por suspender las
elecciones previstas en abril para
elegir a los 155 candidatos
que redactarán la nueva constitución en
chile- la decisión definitiva se tomará
el lunes y martes de la próxima semana